we're here with the incredible billy
porter i am hanging on your every word
you are like church billy listening to
you
is like going to a sermon in
bravery
and ability
and you
have been
so
meaningful
to younger people
also who are trying to find their voices
out there and
i was just curious
what you would say to younger people
um out there who
are just finding their bravery their
truth now yeah there's a lot
of
need
in our culture
for validation
to be validated
and i understand it
what we must understand how to do is
love ourselves enough that the only
validation needed is our own
how long did it take you to learn that
i'm still learning it yeah
it's a constant practice every day
i recommit to it every day
it doesn't matter
what anybody on the outside thinks of
you
do not give your power away to that
and yet is the maya angelou quote
correct in
we can
i'm paraphrasing forgive me maya
how we make people feel yes
yeah nobody's going to remember
what you did it's only going to be what
how you made them feel and i think
that's very important because what i get
from you out in the world
is that the way you make people feel
matters and i think the way all of us
make each other feel matters and it's
liberating to hear
don't
consider or don't take in so much what
people think of you that is the truth
but with that does not come a liberation
of like forget everybody no it's not
that
it's
embrace
take in
yourself
you have to we have to empower
our
selves you know especially with lgbtq
and queer people the conversation for so
long has been about acceptance and
tolerance i have a hard time with that
because that puts
my validation as a human being on this
planet in somebody else's hands i don't
care about your acceptance or your
tolerance what i demand is your respect
for my humanity as i respect every
single person on this planet that is the
new conversation
have you ever thought about
holding a sunday service in a sermon i
cussed too much to be a preacher me too
i like to cuss too much you know they
ain't gonna let me in nobody's church
and yet both of us apparently know where
and when as i tell my kids there's a
time and a place
[Music]
you